Here is our example class again.
Now let's look at the middle compartment which is for purposes of
describing attributes. You'll see that there are different attributes described.
All of them have names. They have types. And they may have some other symbols
that described how the names can be accessed from other classes. Those symbols,
describe the visibility of that name. They're optional you don't have to provide
them and there's no reason, at the start, to do that. They're a refinement that
you add later on in the process. The four options in UML for visibility include.
Publicly visible that's a plus sign. Private, which is a minus sign.
Protect meaning that only sub-classes can access that attribute
is the pound sign. And for those situations where you used UML
packages that tilde indicates that the name is visible within the package.
In addition to the visibility of course you must have the name of the attribute.
You can indicate the multiplicity of ordering of the attribute.
Now they're not shown in this example, but we'll see them later. You should give
the type of the attribute. And UML has a set of built in types that you can use.
You can optionally describe an initial value for that particular instance
variable. You could indicate that the instance variable is derived.
That is it's computed rather than being set directly. And you can give some
additional properties to the instance variable using the the braces
notation that we mentioned before. For example we can indicate that that
particular instance variable is frozen. That means its value can't change.